Jake:就像昨天的那个一样会吗
Jake: Like the one from yesterday, right?
Lucia: 啊procred有录屏的
Lucia: Ah, Procreate has a screen recording feature.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Lucia: 虽然我没有带iPad
Lucia: Although I didn't bring my iPad
Lucia: 所以没有办法用procreate了
Lucia: So I can't use Procreate.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Tasha: 嘿好了好了好了   我我的房间大概就是这个样子的
Tasha: Hey, alright, alright, alright. My room is pretty much like this.
Jake:没关系剧组报销一台我们
Jake: It's okay, the crew will reimburse us for one.
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有
Jake: Haha, just kidding, no.
Alice:报销一下什么
Alice: Reimburse for what?
Lucia: 真的吗
Lucia: Really?
Jake:假的
Jake: Fake.
Alice:额呵呵
Alice: Uh-haha
Lucia: 那我现在立刻就下单
Lucia: Then I'll place an order right away.
Tasha: 那个软件的
Tasha: For that software.
Tasha: procreate
Tasha: Procreate.
Lucia: 这个软件我都买了
Lucia: I already bought this software.
Lucia: 我可以先下到新的那个上面
Lucia: I can download it onto the new one first.
Tasha: procreate这个软件可以买一下吗剧组
Tasha: Can the crew buy Procreate software?
Jake:还没有没有没钱
Jake: No, no, no money.
Jake:这多少钱
Jake: How much is it?
Tasha: 98块钱
Tasha: 98 yuan.
Lucia: 哎现在98了
Lucia: Oh, it's 98 now.
Alice:68吗不是
Alice: Wasn't it 68?
Alice:以前多少
Alice: How much was it before?
Lucia: 88好像 98不记得了
Lucia: I think it was 88, or 98, I don't remember.
Tasha: 到底买的多少钱
Tasha: How much did you buy it for?
Lucia: 我买的时候对是个8结尾的数字
Lucia: When I bought it, it ended with an 8.
Lucia: 但是具体多少我忘了
Lucia: But I forgot the exact amount.
Lucia: 不是一是个
Lucia: Not 1, it was...
Alice:我也记得是个8的数字
Alice: I also remember it being a number ending in 8.
Jake:这是干哈的
Jake: What's it for?
Lucia: 就是那个
Lucia: It's for...
Lucia: 嗯可以画画
Lucia: Um, you can draw with it.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Lucia: 其实也可以做动画
Lucia: You can also make animations.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 但是我水平太差了做不了动画
Lucia: But my skills are too poor to make animations.
Lucia: 哈哈这位妹子应该可以
Lucia: Haha, this girl should be able to.
Tasha: 我
Tasha: I...
Lucia: 她选那个
Lucia: She chose that one.
Lucia: 我应该叫你中文还是叫
Lucia: Should I call you by your Chinese name or...
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Jake:应该叫你什么
Jake: What should we call you?
Jake:我也没整明白
Jake: I'm not sure either.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Tasha: 薇薇
Tasha: Tasha.
Jake:薇薇
Jake: Tasha.
Tasha: 薇薇
Tasha: Tasha.
Lucia: 好的薇薇应该可以
Lucia: Okay, Tasha should be fine.
Jake:只叫薇薇是吗
Jake: Just Tasha, right?
Jake:好嘞薇薇
Jake: Alright, Tasha.
Tasha: ok
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 等一下再擦一擦
Tasha: Wait a second, let me wipe this.
Jake:可以问问管家
Jake: You can ask the butler.
Jake:就是这边的人
Jake: The people over here.
Lucia: 试图获取一些能量
Lucia: Trying to gather some energy.
Jake:能不能帮你把
Jake: Can they help you with...
Alice:试图获取一些灵感
Alice: Trying to get some inspiration.
Lucia: 哈哈哈试图偷盗一些灵感
Lucia: Haha, trying to steal some inspiration.
Alice:我还
Alice: I haven't...
Jake:帮你帮你
Jake: Help you, help you.
Alice:什么都没弄呢
Alice: ...done anything yet.
Jake:把床给卸了
Jake: Take apart the bed.
Jake:额呵
Jake: Uh huh.
Jake:把这个床给挪开
Jake: Move this bed out of the way.
Jake:不知道能不能
Jake: Not sure if we can...
Tasha: 好像就是这样子的
Tasha: Seems like it's just like this.
Tasha: 一个房间
Tasha: A room.
Tasha: 呵呵呵
Tasha: Hehehe.
Tasha: 抄作业中
Tasha: Copying homework.
Alice:我们俩房间不太一样抄不了
Alice: Our rooms are different, can't copy.
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Hehe.
Jake:一般抄作业
Jake: Usually when you copy homework...
Jake:是别人做完的抄吧
Jake: ...you copy after someone finished it, right?
Lucia: 这个从过程就开始抄
Lucia: This one is copying from the process.
Lucia: 就万一被老师问到
Lucia: So if the teacher asks...
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 你就跟他说出来你是怎么做的
Lucia: ...you can explain how you did it.
Lucia: 哈哈也是
Lucia: Haha, exactly.
Jake:也是
Jake: Yeah, right.
Tasha: 抄作业他还扔吗
Tasha: Is he still throwing homework around?
Jake:对我们先下载那个软件
Jake: Yeah, let's download that software first.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 这是我的房间
Tasha: This is my room.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 呵呵呵
Tasha: Hehehe.
Jake:免户型一起抄是吧我们哈哈哈
Jake: Copy the layout together, right? Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈户型抄不了
Lucia: Hahaha, you can't copy the layout.
Alice:户型抄不了
Alice: You can't copy the layout.
Tasha: 然后直接直接从淘宝把图片下载下来
Tasha: Then just directly download the pictures from Taobao.
Tasha: 然后贴上去哈哈
Tasha: And then paste them, haha.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 也可以
Tasha: That works too.
Jake:确实
Jake: True.
Jake:我这房间我是装潢完了
Jake: I've finished decorating this room.
Jake:我是
Jake: I'm...
Alice:就你赛博风
Alice: Just your cyber style.
Lucia: 哈哈你就赛博朋克风
Lucia: Haha, you're all about cyberpunk style.
Jake:赛博朋克风
Jake: Cyberpunk style.
Jake:确实装饰了我一晚上哈哈
Jake: It really took me all night to decorate, haha.
Lucia: 很暴力细薇你可以再加点什么彩灯啊什么
Lucia: It's very aggressive, Tasha, you can add some colorful lights or something.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's fine.
Jake:额呵呵更赛博了
Jake: Uh, hehe, even more cyber now.
Tasha: 装饰
Tasha: Decorations.
Lucia: 染色了都
Lucia: It's all dyed.
Tasha: 装饰可以放到不同的地方自由组合
Tasha: You can freely combine the decorations in different places.
Alice:对对对
Alice: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:更赛博了
Jake: Even more cyber.
Tasha: 老自由了
Tasha: Very free.
Jake:更睡不了觉了
Jake: Even harder to sleep now.
Alice:好累啊想洗澡了
Alice: I'm so tired, I want to take a shower.
Tasha: 洗
Tasha: Go ahead.
Alice:现在
Alice: Now?
Jake:现在呢行啊
Jake: Now? Sure.
Tasha: 去吗
Tasha: Are you going?
Jake:可以啊
Jake: Yeah, go ahead.
Tasha: 去吧
Tasha: Go ahead.
Jake:下班吧
Jake: Let's call it a day.
Alice:现在
Alice: Now?
Alice:这个能点了
Alice: This can be clicked.
Jake:下班吧下班吧
Jake: Time to get off work.
Lucia: 哦太好了那我就上去洗衣服
Lucia: Oh great, I'll go upstairs and do the laundry.
Alice:手机呢
Alice: Where's my phone?
Jake:好
Jake: Got it.
Alice:哦在这
Alice: Oh, here it is.
Katrina: 关机
Katrina: Turn it off.
Katrina: 进入休眠状态
Katrina: Enter sleep mode.
Jake:可以下班
Jake: We can get off work now.
Tasha: 好刀郎拜拜
Tasha: Okay, bye Daolang.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:今日杀青
Jake: That's a wrap for today.